hi everybody so
um i'm sarah groff palermo super sgp on
twitter if you want to say nice things
about me while i'm talking
um this is the same talk that i did
yesterday
powered by javascript they were really
nice
to ask me to come fill in for last
cancellation here at strange loop so
i'm really excited to get to share this
with more people but if you've seen it
before it's totally the same thing
so just a little bit about me to start
i'm a designer originally who basically
taught myself to code because
i wanted to make the weird things that i
could imagine and i didn't want to keep
begging all of my dev friends to help me
make it so
i just sort of figured it out piece by
piece to do it myself
so i'm going to talk today about art.js
which is not
a library i realized it sort of sounded
like one after we came up with the title
but um instead it's about the fine craft
of making art
with javascript and data something i
like to call data art
we're not going to talk a whole lot
about code in this talk there's not
going to be any code samples up on the
screen
mostly i think you're all smart people
who like to figure things out i'll talk
a little bit about
what each thing is made with and a lot
of it is d3 which um
there's a lot of really good resources
for working with it
but instead i want to talk to you about
sort of the mechanisms
of data art and why you should think
about making it and we'll look at some
examples and some process and hopefully
by the end you'll all be really excited
and want to go out and make your own
stuff and share it with all of us
that's my dream uh so
another quick note which is uh about the
word
art sometimes the word art is a scary
word people like to argue
about what's art and what's design and
what's not art and you know
it's really fun to like go to the bar
and get drunk with your friends and
argue about that it's one of the perks
of being an artist
and i highly recommend it but
today i'm just going to take the
broadest interpretation um
which is to say that art is exploring
things you like
experimenting making something and then
calling it art and that's all that it
takes and you know
somebody wants to argue with you you can
send them to me and i'll tell them no
that's
art you made it you said it's art that's
it
all right caveats are done um so the
next thing is to sort of define our
terms
and a really important question is what
is data art and how does it relate
to data visualization how do we
distinguish them is data art just
pretty data visualization it's not
they're different
but to talk about how they're different
i like to do things backwards we're
going to start with what they have in
common
and what the two have in common is that
they're both about the investigation of
information
and they might be very different kinds
of detectives you know one might be
more of a sherlock and the other one
might be you know
more of a phillip marlow let's say but
in their heart they're
about investigating information
and they are structures that are set up
around the kinds of information we
classify as data right which is to say
things that can be structured to be
dealt with algorithmically and that's
really important sometimes when you make
art
when you draw when you paint it's long
and it's tedious and it's hard but the
really awesome part about making art
with computers is you can make the
computer do all the hard parts for you
so if that's how they're the same let's
talk about how they're different there's
sort of
three basic methods that we can
distinguish them along the types of data
each works with their goals and then
therefore the types of expression used
to achieve those goals
the first one the kind of data sort of
goes on a spectrum from
comprehensive on the one hand to
fragmented on the other
traditional data visualization right is
organized around an ideal data set
that's as comprehensive and unbiased as
possible
and anybody who does data visualization
will tell you that that never actually
happens that data set doesn't exist but
it's the dream and people are working
towards using that kinds of data
which is to say that you know you're
looking for these related quantifiable
metrics that are all available and then
once you've pulled all of these little
points together
you look and find the best patterns and
the best stories that you can tell from
that collection and that's the dream of
traditional data visualization
on the other hand for data art the ideal
data set
is small fragmented and incomplete it's
human and hopefully in some ways
personal personal to you or to the kind
of story that you want to tell
and these data sets are different right
because the goals of the work
are different um traditional dataviz
wants to communicate
information they they want to tell you
you know
what is known or a way to say it is what
they've found
on the other hand data art is looking to
communicate an experience a thing we
know through living like a novel might
and
you could say that they're looking to
express what they've felt as opposed to
what they found
so this is a really important
distinction and when you have different
goals of course you have different types
of expression
and here's the first example we'll have
there's lots of examples in this i have
a big web page up that has all the links
so you guys can look them up later but
um
so this is the first and this is an
example of sort of like an ideal
information communicating visualization
from the new york times
you know you can see that it has a very
high pixel to information density ratio
and you know while there's a story
picked out here and little points called
out for you to understand the
information
you're also totally capable of accessing
all of the precise points you can see
there in the gray that
if you wanted to know why the line is
where it is how they averaged it out you
can sort of see how these are the means
perfectly there and find each and every
number and that's
a really great data visualization on the
other hand here's a piece of data art
this is a work by lori frick called
nightly sleep analyzed
and you can see so this implied x-axis
here is the number of hours of sleep
she's had and the y-axis is sort of the
months of the year
and each of the squares show travel and
socialization and it's less about sort
of
you can look up how much sleep lori
frick got on january 28th
and more the expression of the rhythm of
her life of her year right you can see
that it gets really exciting towards the
end of the year the quiet at the
beginning of the year and
while the you know work well the
fundamental underlying piece of it is
data
that's not really what it's looking to
express
and we'll find later in some of the
examples that some data art doesn't even
result in a visual result at all it can
be
you know words or something else and
that's great too right that the art is
somehow the least visual
of the kind of work you can do
okay so now that we know what data art
is you might say why should we do why
should we make it
um you know i'm excited about it but you
don't have any reason to be at least not
yet
so four reasons to undertake it one is
to understand ourselves
the second is to understand the systems
to which we are subject
and to which we subject others right
we're social animals and
it's important to understand what kinds
of things are happening with the
assumptions that we make
the third is to expand our horizons uh
daily speaking so in terms of making
data visualizations
and the fourth and most important reason
to do this is because it's fun
and if it's not fun then don't do it you
know like do other things that you think
are fun because
we all go to work every day and if
you're going to make cool stuff you
should do it because you love it
so let's talk a little bit about
understanding ourselves
this is sort of where i start to talk
about cliches right we live in a time of
accelerating technical change and as
programmers we ourselves are at the
heart of it which is
awesome but if our tools are changing
quickly
as humans we're probably changing less
and definitely less quickly than the
possibilities we can imagine
but if the people who are shaping the
interaction of technology
are only those who are the most excited
about it you know we can end up with a
sort of
lopsided and constrained implementation
that doesn't do justice to us
and that is a risk we run you know
science and technology have their
own biases including assumptions about
objectivity
and you know what data means and it's
really hard to critique that within its
own system
the way it talks about itself sort of
precludes it
which is to say something like if you
focus only on the kinds of truth that
traditional data orbits around
then you start to think that that is the
most important and the most true
and you can privilege the concerns of
the engineers and people designing the
system over the people using it and we
wouldn't want to do something like that
meanwhile humanities particularly
history and literature
sort of have as their project you know
placing human activities into context
and then systematically criticizing them
in pursuit of understanding
and if they merely turn up their noses
at tech they're abandoning their
missions and i'm here today talking to
you about this but
i also sometimes go and work with people
who work in the digital humanities to
get
you know english professors and history
professors and other people using tech
in their work as well
and i do that because together i think
they have super powers when we bring
humanities and tech together
each makes up for the others shortfalls
and opens a window into who we were
before the web
and who will continue to be with it and
we can understand ourselves
and make decisions that are good for
today and good for tomorrow
and part of making good decisions is to
understand the systems to which we
subject ourselves
and other people and so
originally a long time ago my i studied
in my degree is in literary theory
and literary theory really is about
looking at these systems you know and
seeing how they're played out
in our lives and i love it and it's
great and it's wonderful
and so i've always thought a little bit
about this but it started to seem more
important to me
so this summer i went to a conference
called io
and it's basically a conference full of
people who like to make
data art and data visualization and all
the kinds of stuff i enjoy
and one of the kinds of projects people
make is something like selfie city
which you can see here and it uses
metadata both machine made
and human generated they used a lot of
mechanical turk work to help classify
photos um to sort of understand how
humans differ from city to city by
gender by age when they're taking
selfies to understand something about us
but so we're at this conference talking
about all these kinds of work that we
like to do
but this year was a little bit different
and people were a little on edge and a
little defensive and a little bit sad
and that's because
in between the conference before and the
conference this summer it turned out
that someone else was all up in our
metadata right um
all of a sudden this thing that we had
loved in like this little corner of the
world being like we just like to make
data art with fun stuff
it was making people scared people were
like i don't want my data out there how
are people going to use it what are they
going to do to me you know and
they felt really threatened and i think
that that's important
and then again right we come home from
the conference and all of a sudden it
turns out you know there's a facebook
news feed experiment where
researchers and data you know and the
company data scientists were changing
people's news feeds
showing them only happier only sad stuff
to see if it affected
how they felt and you know some people
argued oh facebook already manipulates
their news feed
it's fine you shouldn't be upset um and
you know and you can sort of agree with
that end or the other end i mean clearly
sheryl sandberg doesn't give a [ __ ]
like she was manipulating her newsfeed
um
but it's clear that right both of these
things made people feel super threatened
and you know and i think because we like
to make work
with this kind of data it was really
hard for us to watch
but this is the cool thing when we make
art we can take
back those sorts of tools and use them
to tell
our stories and insert ourselves into it
in a way that's our own tiny little way
of pushing back
against you know people just using your
data for things that you don't want them
to
all right that was a long one the third
one is to expand our horizons and this
is far more sort of practical and
prosaic right
when you make when we make work with
database we want to communicate things
we want to pull people into these
stories
and so you experiment with adding in
some feeling or doing stuff like that
right
but sometimes it doesn't work out so
great
um this is a piece by reuters that was
showing right the um
the gun death rate in florida around the
stand your ground law
and um sadly because she was focused on
actually communicating the information
of you know this blood
dripping down in the sadness but it
actually shows the totally wrong story
right it looks like it goes down when it
goes up
and that's a big problem so we want to
make art so that we can start you know
playing around with things in a nice way
that perhaps runs fewer risks
and a really good example of that is
this work by georgia loopy
and her studio acurat and what this is
is it's a visualization
actually of auction prices for art to
see if art is selling for a lot more
than people expected
i think it's you know a really pretty
bird-flocking view
and it's really engaging and that's
something that you're looking for when
you want to tell people a story you want
to engage them
and so loopy made this really artistic
visualization and she starts off by
looking at actual art that's this piece
in the middle here um is a modernist
drawing and she
sketches them and copies over them and
starts to think about how she can make
something similar driven by data so
that's like a
great reason to play with this and
reason number four is like i said before
it's fun and being fun is really
important not only for us like i was
talking about before
but it's important to make data
something that's not just
unfun you know sometimes a lot of
quantified self stuff can be
about scolding you this is the happy
fork i like to call it the scoldy fork
what it does is it tracks how quickly
you're eating your food and if you're
eating it too fast
it yells at you um
you know and this is the kinds of things
sometimes you see people make with data
and the ability to make quantified self
you know that it's like
oh we have these watches now and we can
track every single thing we do but like
if you're only using it to make yourself
feel bad because you ate your cake too
fast like is that really
what we're looking for so you should
make fun stuff with it so that we don't
just leave it
in the realm of the unfun and the scoldy
all right examples even more examples
so the examples that i'm going to go
through are sort of broken down
um into two wide groups
the literary approach which i think of
as you know
using data with the same sort of
workings as we use books and i'll talk a
little bit about that
and then the second kind is sort of work
where
just language and literature are the
data we're using
to express our art so they're two
different approaches that i like
but there's great examples in both so
the literary approach
you remember a little bit before when i
was talking about traditional data
visualization right
all these points wrapped together so we
can find a pattern and that tells us
certain things but
it doesn't tell us very much about
ourselves personally i mean if i look at
an average of people like me
i don't see myself in it i mean i'm not
average are you average probably not
um but we can sort of approach it and
find ourselves in data
in a different way and that's the
literary way and so if you think about
it right
literature and books particularly
fiction uh they work
by getting you to identify with
characters who have absolutely nothing
to do with you right i love to read
mysteries about
like a fat french policeman in the turn
of the 20th century and you know that
he's nothing like me but by creating
this work
of words on a page and expecting us to
use
our imagination and our empathy to bring
this work to life
authors do a great job they make us
start understanding what it's like to be
somebody other than us and so there's
data works too
where people you know leave holes that
you fill in with your knowledge with
things other people know and really
bring them to life
the first example i'm going to talk
about is called first chapters there's
actually two iterations of it
there was originally a manual version
drawn out and done with illustrator
and the data was all collected manually
and then there's a secondary version
that somebody made with d3
so stephanie posevec who made the
original one
the way that first chapters works is
she's visualizing novel openings as
connected sentences
the length of the line matches the
length of the sentence and they go
around and around in a very pleasing
layout
until the end of the chapter is reached
and
you know it's the abstraction of an
experience the formal expression of the
novel is
expressed on the page hemingway is known
for his brevity but here we see his
sentences are long
and his chapters are short and airy
meanwhile here's 1984 all cluttered up
on top of itself sentence upon sentence
piling up
becoming almost as claustrophobic and
dystopian as the novel itself
then right we have the great gatsby
which is an interesting interstitial it
has some dense points as
you know nick's imagination wanders
around and some longer points connecting
all of them
um and it's lovely each of these is an
expression of what it's like
to read that novel to experience its
form
and you can project yourself in it and
it's really great so she did this
manually and then
by moving it into programming by using
d3 and making it interactive with
javascript right we open up even
another aspect to it which is great jim
vlandingham is the one who did this
um and you can start to even find
mistakes on our own algorithms when you
start visualizing them
because i'm a jerk i pulled out the
mistake that i found
which is that you know a sentence is
being counted incorrectly because i
think he's using a period as a delimiter
and so right mr
just flops that around so
so we can make cooler we can expand on
it with our friends and find out neat
stuff
um the second example is a day in the
life which is about taxis and this
is all javascripted up it uses the node
package for mapbox
it uses d3 on the front end for drawing
and then leaflet
for serving the map this is the map that
we have so
basically um chris wong took taxi data
from new york and instead of sort of
visualizing
the averages of taxis and what they're
doing here he's just visualized um
as you reload it you can get a different
taxi driver each time but you can see
the drivers driving around
picking up fares dropping them off and
you know this is a very anecdotal story
you're seeing what it's like to be
that taxi driver and then you know it's
nice to have another little trapdoor in
it if you know new york
you can also start telling stories about
the passengers you know when i see
somebody going
up to the upper east side at nine
o'clock in the morning all the way over
by the river i know they're going to the
hospital and then you can start asking
questions are they
having a baby are they going to work but
there's this whole great story
buried in it that draws you in and we
can start imagining what it's like to be
all of these other people
um the next one oh hey i made this
mistake yesterday and i didn't fix it
um so the next two things we're going to
look at is quantified breakup and then
frick bits and they're interesting
because they approach the same problem
from two
totally opposite sides so
quantified breakup this is the piece
where the data itself is the most
personal it covers
the artist's divorce so she starts
making charts of you know
bubble charts of what she's bought to
help her feel better little line charts
about the support of people who've
called her and texted her over the time
these maps of cathartic subway ventures
and each chart together right works to
crack open an
aspect of her breakup in recovery that
just like words on a page
tell a full story by being pulled
altogether
and a totally different approach is
frick bits which just had a very
successful kickstarter it's the artist
lori frick that i showed
earlier um it's pretty much the inverse
she's taking the most traditional
location data
um but making it more personal and
approachable by rendering it to look
hand-drawn and hand-painted and this app
i think should be out pretty soon
um and so while they're both different
they're both rooted in using
personalized data to take control to as
laurie frick says
make a tick mark in the column of i am
not a data victim
and it shows a way to make some really
exciting work
the last the last sort of literary
approach piece is something that i've
made and this is called the timeline of
neglect
and i don't know about you but i buy
books and then i just like leave them on
my shelf
unread and i feel really guilty about
this um i get so excited when i see them
at the bookstore and then i take them
home and have to do other things
so what i've done here is i'm
visualizing
my books decaying over time as i leave
them there the line gets longer it fades
out
um you know and so i i'd like to
actually make a
hardware version of it where i can you
know just stick them on a little
on a little thing to see it fall apart
but um
yeah so this is another right way that
i'm trying to communicate this
experience of something that i know is
going on in our world that's sort of
hard to see
and in each of these examples data
becomes not merely the aggregated
numbers
and whose patterns we seek to find
ourselves but instead becomes the stuff
by which
we express the specifics of who we are
whether you know
it's book guilt or a divorce or we're a
taxi driver
and you know we live in a time that
speaks itself in data so we're using the
language
of today to express today there's also
a really great opportunity right um in
discussing how genres are formed
jonathan culler who's a literary
theorist he calls literature a
paradoxical institution
it's an institution that lives by
exposing and criticizing its own limits
by testing what will happen if one
writes differently you know what happens
if we
code differently and we can make use of
the questions
that are very common questions that
people ask when they're you know
analyzing literature you can ask
who is speaking you know who's speaking
what language and with what authority
and when you start to look at sort of
right
one step outside then not only are you
empathizing with people but you're
starting to see something else going on
to see how the outside
world is working on what we do and what
we say about what we do
and you know as we interrogate all of
these methods
um we look for what underlies it and
you know in the end we turn out to
reveal ourselves
all right so now we're going to talk
about language's data
which is a different approach and in
this approach
a lot of the works don't end up really
being a visualization at the end
but are still i think fun interesting
works
so um in task of the translator which is
another
piece of literary theory that i was
always a big fan of um
walter benjamin talks a little bit about
how impossible
translation is that meaning
really adheres to an object in a
cultural context and a way to talk about
that is to think that like
if you're translating something from
french into german you can't really just
say
pen is brought right bread is something
different to a french person than to a
german growing up in that culture they
mean something differently
and so when you start to translate
things what happens is you start to find
a space where meanings don't adhere
quite as tightly
and it tells you a little bit about both
of those cultures coming into contrast
and we can do something sort of like
this by playing with language and
algorithmic structures
and to keep it from being boring
sometimes we make it pretty and
sometimes we make it absurd
so on the pretty end this uh patatap is
a piece done by john o'brien lola tone
and they actually call it
a sound animation kit and if you go
online and play with this there's fun
noises that go with it too
but part of the reason it's interesting
to me is you type on your keyboard to
create these visualizations and then you
hit the space bar to change the register
and it's a way to sort of understand how
merely changing a register can take the
same
inputs and make them seem very different
and that's an
abstract point but i think it's
important when we start to think
about systems and interactions to you
know just see it
distill down into these colors
we can also sort of see in a different
way some of the more absurd ways of
combining
pattern and language generation and
these are a patent generator and some
twitter bots
so sam levine created a patent generator
um it creates patent applications out of
literature
uh using the pattern library actually
and i know that someone's going to be
talking about using
that today about looking at rap lyrics
so i'm really excited about that talk um
but sam levine here has used it to
combine works of literature and history
with patent applications
that sort of shows you know what's go
what are the assumptions we're making
when we write patents and these are
the kinds of patents um you would make
for the communist manifesto so
communist manifesto is i can't read this
here because that's over there it's a
system for generating you know
revolutions and all sorts of exciting
things um
but it tells us something both about
patents and you know about an entire
about an interesting piece of literature
likewise there's nodebots um these are
two of my favorites
uh one of them is two headlines which is
by darius kazemi who goes by tiny
subversions
the other is the game idea machine and i
don't remember who it's by and i keep
forgetting to look it up
so but in this case right they're both
playing again with the structure of
language and the assumptions we make in
two headlines darius kazemi just
switches out
various nouns and you can see that the
structure of the headlines makes it make
sense perhaps in an absurd way
all the same time likewise with the game
idea machine we see implications about
how we think about making games it's
great because
it almost becomes really repetitive but
in some ways right it might point to
limitations in the way we conceive of
the games
that are popular to make now
and then the last example of structural
work that's really interesting
is less art than history and this is
work
by the historian matthew connolly and
what he does
is he uses data and the structure of
data
to look at redacted government documents
and
figure out where they should be making
foia requests what sorts of things they
should be looking for
um merely by the structure of what's
missing and i mean i think that's
beautiful right like
it's history but it's also art like that
by what's missing
you can start to find out what to
explore
so those are all sorts of the different
ways that you can work with language and
literature
and art and data and put it all up on
the web using javascript
so now you're all really excited right
you're ready to like totally leave and
go make art right now
um but you're like oh okay i'm ready to
go but what am i gonna make
uh so i like to come up with topics in
three different ways
that might be sort of ways to start
turning over what you know
you can start with topics you can start
with tools and you can start with
translation
so with topics you might ask yourself
questions about you know what do you
love that has nothing to do with tech
what sort of
fuzzy strange thing can you drag into
this world of rules and
make crazy stuff with also you know what
system has assumptions you want to
explore what do you want to go poke at
what dark spots do you want to shine
light on
and you know you have the right thing
when you can't stop talking about it at
all
sometimes that doesn't work though and
then you say okay but maybe there's
tools that i want to play with
on the d3 on the d3 website there's a
huge gallery full of beautiful layouts
and visualizations and i've definitely
made stuff by saying
i want to figure out how to make you
know a sunburst tree map
where can i find data that's the right
kind of data to mess around with this
um likewise some really fun node stuff
there's also this pattern library that i
mentioned before
and then toppo time which i still
haven't figured out what i want to do
with but it's really exciting to me
it's a way about structuring data about
time
when you don't have precise time data if
you can say i know that this happened
before this
and after this or you can say something
like
the first 10 summers of my life x
happened
that's the kind of data that you can put
into toppo time
which is built on top of d3 by elijah
meeks who actually
i think he has a book downstairs about
d3 at the manning table but uh
right you can start playing with this
and that might be a really fun tool to
make work with
the third way is what i like to call
translation right
can you make some remake something that
you think is beautiful driven by data
these are just um silver prints it's
metal foil inside wax i think they're
super lovely and you know
i start to wonder what what kind of data
could i use
what could i do to come out with
something that looks a little bit
like this all right
so we know we want to make stuff we have
an idea
what do you do what's what kind of
process um this is going to be a little
bit of a fast one because you guys all
write code which means you all already
know everything about the creative
process
this is just this is just a little bit
more fun because now you don't have to
justify what you're doing to like your
project managers or your clients or
anyone else but it's the same sort of
thing right
so i'd like to start with sketching uh
this is that piece again that georgia
loopy really liked and so you can start
by
copying art you like just to get a feel
for it to get yourself going
or you know you can sketch what you want
to make it's a really good way to
iterate through ideas right
you can always throw away the pieces of
paper when you don't like what you do on
them
and then once you know what you want to
make you can gather your data
and remember this part does not have to
be perfect all of the book work i've
done
is literally just me sitting in my house
entering like data about my books into a
csv like that's
it um and you want it to have holes and
be a little rough because right that's
the whole fun of this part um
so then you have all your data together
and then you're going to test it out
you're going to fail and you're going to
try again and it's going to go over and
over and over again
this is this doodle was made by a woman
named joe bradshaw
to illustrate a tweet by marcus romer
about the creative process right how you
feel
it starts with this is awesome then this
is tricky
this is [ __ ] i am [ __ ] this might be
okay
and finally back to this is awesome
and it will happen right and it's worth
sticking it out
um and there's lots of really good ways
to stick it out and sometimes what you
get is nothing like what you wanted in
the first place so
this is another thing i made dot it's
also about my books i like to make
things about
my books but you can see on the left
that first sketch is
absolutely nothing like the second piece
that's come up that also has sound
um but by
you know hitting my head against a wall
over and over and over again i ended up
making something
that i think is wonderful and like i
said before there's a lot of really
great d3 resources
i have even more up on my website but
you know
interactive data visualization is by
scott murray and then d3js in action by
elijah meeks
these two books i think are great um the
scott murray one is a little bit more
i've never done d3 before it can be
finicky so it's sort of worth
you know taking a look at how it's weird
uh and then
d3.js in action is a little bit more
intermediate there are some great people
too who blog about it including irene
rose
and shirley wu and then if you're in san
francisco
there is the gray area foundation for
the arts which i think is amazing they
just got
a huge theater on mission street then
now they're you know
doing creative coding classes and
immersives and they have
meetups and all sorts of different art
shows and stuff and i think that
if this is the kind of stuff that
excites you i've pretty much never gone
to a meet-up with them that i didn't
leave wanting to do
500 other things they're great
so then that's you know the last step is
just to share you know
make it work show it to other people see
what happens
you know it has to start off being for
you so if you keep exploring eventually
you will find your audience i think
there's a writer austin cleon right
who's like
just keep putting it up and keep doing
the things you believe in and the people
who also believe in that will find you
as long as you do it and share it
um so you know that's it ask questions
poke at stuff
make your computer do all of the hard
work for you
express your incomplete truths share it
eventually and you know
if you keep doing that then your
understanding and mine will grow
and we can make some really really
awesome stuff so
thank you guys so much
we have a couple minutes left if people
have questions yeah
um
one of the things that i found with my
data visualization
is that if i i call it like cartoonize
it
if i transform it into art a little bit
more
that the understanding you know of my
audience increases
and is quicker and faster but at the
same time
i feel um a kind of ambivalence about
this because i feel a bit paternalistic
almost you know my background is in
statistics and i like
high you know i like statistics i like
the
density that is you know data
visualization will give
so how do i balance that with my users
like how do i
you know are there strategies for
meeting
you know users that have different
capabilities well
you know how do i balance databases
so the question just to repeat um is how
do you
balance sort of data visualization and
data art if you're working in data
visualization and you find that you know
some amount of arting it up brings users
in but a lot of times people who are
working with data very much come from a
statistics background who
like to have all the information what do
you do what are your strategies for
finding the balance
i think there's a couple of interesting
ways people have approached it you know
i think the new york times does a great
job
of basically walking people through a
data set
and then at the end having a sandbox
that everyone can play with they
recently did something about
incomes for various uh you know incomes
going up and down across a whole bunch
of different categories of working
groups
and you know when you first look at it's
this like overwhelming line chart but
you scroll through and it calls things
out and then at the end it has them all
broken out and you can play with it i
think that's a really
big step i think something else that
helps too
is remembering that people
who aren't sort of drawn in the question
isn't showing people everything and
showing them a little bit
sometimes the question is getting people
to understand a little bit
and getting people to close the browser
window and go somewhere else because
it's just too much so
less than sort of like betraying your
mission you know you can think of it i
think
as a step series of groups that you
bring people in and they get excited and
they get excited and then some of those
people eventually will
be more like you and want to like dig
into all of the deep stuff but it's a
process i think
anyone else
awesome i'm happy i answered all of your
questions with these slides um
so thank you guys so much you can find
me online you can find links to the
things that we make if you follow me
i will be making more posts about all
the weird stuff i make and see
and i hope you'll share something you
make with me too so thanks so much guys